Laca
Sandra your account has been permanently
baned please visit
[Musik]
minecraft.com ja Leute wir spielen heute
mal wieder one block ich h eine Bombe
das ist ein Creeper warte warte okay wir
bauen wieder unser Loch bist du bereit
für mein Skill ja ja Leute ich dachte
also nice guck mal W da
oh ist
das eine Katze alle schreiben er ist so
gefährlich diger dann z ich den jetzt
ein kann nicht wahr sein ein paar
Sekunden später was machst du ich baue
jetzt ein Stall für die für wen für die
Jaguar das ergibt gar keinen Sinn das
ist kein Jaguar das ist eine Katze das
ist keine guck mal wie die gehen das ist
keine Katze Sandra google mal Minecraft
jag wie schnell die sind ja weil die
Angst V dir haben guck mal Sandy was ich
uns gebaut habe ja danke für
nichts wie danke für nichts voll die
gute Idee wenn Creeper kommt können wir
es einfach aufmachen so können wir
rüberlufen so oh Sandy Bau du mal kurz
bitte ne ne ich bin ich bin weg nee weil
ich muss mal kurz hier was bei den
Kisten muss ich machen ganz dringend ich
ma hier gar nichts Sand jetzt hau die
Hexe mal da runter du muss auch mal
[Musik]
lernen
oh mein Gott was hat denn
gemacht oh
Schleim was ein Schleim was bedeutet
das der Frosch hat den Schleim gegessen
was war das denn
diger pass mal
auf
[Musik]
wer das Sandra in den Chat schreibt wird
bei mir blockiert nur wenige Minuten
später
la hast du gerade Kaninchen
getötet alles archoll Sandra eine
gefälschte Warnung bezüglich
Accountlöschung von
mirhten L King ist übrigens der diesen
Server hier gemacht hat und der
kommuniziert manchmal bei uns über das
Symbol über den Chat ja dann mach mal
bro ja Leute mein Haus MS ich natürlich
auch noch irgendwie bauen aber ich habe
noch keine genaue Idee wie ich das
[Musik]
was
was Gericht was chines vertrauen was
hast Du denn gemacht in Minecraft
hast oh
mcft oh mein Gott du musst dein Skin ern
und wie ma ich das prank Leute sie muss
Skin nicht ern bei mir kam es auch
gerade im Chat bei mir kam hello Sandra
s nein die haben sogar deinen Namen soll
ich das mal übersetzen für dich hallo
Sandra s wir haben vor kurzem mehrere
Beschwerden gegen dein Account für einen
nicht angemessenen Skin also nicht
angemessen Aussehen erhalten unser
Moderator hat sich das angeschaut in
diesem Fall und identifiziert das so als
wäre das gegen die Minecraft Community
Richtlinien du musst deinen Skin
innerhalb der nächsten 60 Minuten ändern
um zu verhindern d b wir halten uns vor
Aktion gegen de Account Unternehmen und
suspendieren dich permanent also immer
und deine ipadress kannst keinen neuen
Account machen von der Minecraft
Community willst du mal versuchen zu
antworten oder so wie kann ich den
Antworten drück t einfach und dann bist
Du im Chat kannst ja keine Ahnung
schreib einfach ja du sollst jetzt nicht
t Antworten aber warum hello sorry I
[Musik]
think
du
kleiner schreib den frag keine Ahnung
wie lange noch hast oder so ich weiß
[Musik]
nicht visit
minecraft.com B am Arsch soll ich Malia
eben anrufen ja ist mein Manager was
geht ich bin gerade Mute im Chat Sandra
haben wir geprankt dass sie angeblich in
minecraft Account für immer verliert und
sie perma gebannt ist Spiel mal mit
Sandy hörst du
Ilia ja also erklär mal erklär mal kurz
dein Problem ich wurde gebannt
permanent
bei Minecraft we ich Bikini an hatte oh
mann ja das ist schwierig das kriegt man
so einfach nicht
zurück also fast unmöglich eigentlich
und jetzt ist meine Minecraft kriere
jetzt schon vorbei hä von paar Sachen
aber bei erstmal ja also das ist gar
nicht gut ja meinst du wir können da
jetzt noch wen erreichen ir um 20 Uhr
das ist auch schwierig wahrscheinlich ne
selbst wenn wir wenn wir jemanden
erreichten heißt nicht umsonst permab
ich würde sagen wir probieren es jetzt
noch mal du kannst ja vielleicht mal
direkt jetzt den den den Minecraft
Leuten von uns da schreiben und ja da
halt direkt Bescheid geben was Phase ist
und das S insin ändert schau mal was ich
machen lässt ja
okay ja aber nicht gut Leute na ja gut
na ja dan für die Info okay versuch mal
zu regeln okay ich bin jetzt gerade auf
gute
frage.net gute frage.net so dum probier
wir noch mal auf de Server zu kommen was
passiert dann ich ich guck mal gerade
deinen Stream hierbei bin
drin jetzt bist du drin normal oder was
ja bist du vorhin direkt rausgeflogen
oder wie ja
[Applaus]
sorenticed that you with the wrong
Player oh s du hast aber dein Skin
geändert ne ja ich seh jetzt aus wie du
ja echt
bisschen also die haben festgestellt
dass du mit dem danke mit dem falschen
Spieler unterwegs war das heißt alles
gut oder wie dann schreib mir noch mal
in chat dass du irend Entschädigung
haben möchtest oder oh mein Gott money
Alter Sekunden
später
[Musik]
nein ach oh mein Gott nein jetzt kommen
die an dass sie dich bannen weil du dich
nicht angemessen verhalten hast nachdem
du endbannt wurdest weil du nach Geld
gefragt
hast
ich schreib den Chat warte ich schreib
den Chat dass du eigentlich das Geld von
mir wolltest ne Team
[Musik]
minecraftoney
money wenn jetzt könen weitermchen das
ma kein Spaß wenn ich die ganze Zeit
gebannt
werde
Leute was ist das ich als ob die uns
jetzt hier zugucken im Stream ich B auch
mal weiter MSS irgend bisschen
Vorankommen ich meine wir sind bei ob
count Lua das Scheiße Schärfe
Haltbarkeit und noch ein
[Musik]
schleimball